you know we showed you the video we're
going to show about 20 seconds of it uh
in just a moment yesterday of kirsten
cinema being harassed at arizona state
university where activists an illegal
immigrant that is what she is an illegal
immigrant okay whether that offends you
or not chased her into the bathroom a
bunch of other activists did they're not
happy that she won't sign off on this
3.5 trillion dollar bill she has her
reasons she's not as sort of bananas
lefty as most of the other democrats are
and her and joe manchin are holding the
line on this along with all of the
republicans but the activist base
uh is not happy so they chased her first
into the bathroom here's a little bit of
that
okay i'll be back
today we want to talk to you real quick
can we talk to your okay actually i am
heading out
but um right now is a real moment that
our people need in order for us to be
able to talk about what's really
happening
we need a buildback better plan right
now
we we're not gonna go over we need
solutions to build that better plan need
has the solutions that we need we
knocked on doors for you to get you
elected
okay so there's a lot more of that if
you want to see the extended version of
it you can watch our show from yesterday
the danger in this of course is that if
we allow citizens be they legal
or not although if you're not legal
you're not a citizen if we allow people
that are in america
to chase politicians into bathrooms and
to follow them home and whatever else is
coming or is happening right now do you
see why this could lead us to a very
very bad place that whatever republican
politicians do democrat activists will
show up for whatever democrat
politicians do republican activists will
show for and we will end up in creating
a situation that will start getting
extremely dangerous like at some level
she was threatened there but you know
what uh nobody no mainstream people were
offering her any defense yesterday yeah
the usual crazies online were offering
her defense uh and by the way if that
was
aoc going to the bathroom and there were
say magga supporters trump supporters
following into the her into the bathroom
yelling at her first off not only would
that be you know front page news
everywhere right it would be non-stop
insurrection too they're coming but i
would speak out against it obviously i
don't like aoc i think she's an idiot i
think she's a bad actor i think she's
dumb i think she's ridiculous i think
she's
all of the worst things about our public
discourse and and her ideas
whatever ideas are actually hers are
completely antithetical to everything
that i've spent my life now trying to
promote right but i would not be for
activists chasing her into a bathroom or
activists chasing her stalking her at
home or anything else but the left
because they believe politics is
everything right no god no belief but
you end up believing in something and
they believe that politics is everything
so you're allowed to do whatever you
want to get to those ends so not only
did that happen yesterday but then
kirsten cinema got on an airplane and
you're not gonna believe it but an
activist was there as well
how are you
good
sorry i'm just i'm teddy now i don't
know if you remember me i just want to
know if um
you can commit as my senator as you if
you can commit
to passing a reconciliation
that could provide a pathway to
citizenship
for
immigrants
we have been waiting for this for too
long i just need to know if you can
commit
to passing about your reconciliation
that would include immigration and
citizenship for people to be protected
like me and many others
can you commit to that senator
i'm being
vulnerable right now to you my dad
passed away
but my dad passed away
my dad passed away last year and we
didn't get to
reunite with my family i don't want to
disturb you but at the same time i just
want to see if you i can get a
commitment from you
i don't want to disturb you but i just
want to get a commitment that you'll do
what i want as we're on a plane right
now and we're not going to socially
distance and i'm going to get my head
this close to you and everything else
can i be very clear this is why i now
fly first class because of the curtain
that curtain people can't get through
the curtain they see the curtain they
don't know what's happening on the other
side of the curtain they wonder they
know there's a cleaner bathroom up there
they suspect that it's cleaner it's got
to be cleaner than what's going on in
the back of the plane but they fear the
curtain they don't want to touch the
curtain they don't want to move around
the curtain and then someone will yell
at them you can't come up here that's
the bathroom for these people so cinema
i guess she's a woman of the people it
looks like she was uh sitting in coach
and not on the other side but kirsten if
you watch the show i would highly
recommend first or business class
because the curtain it's an iron curtain
and it'll keep them out do you
understand cinema
anyway the point of this is that we are
now saying sort of in society you can
approach these people at any moment you
can guilt them i mean that girl it
doesn't even matter what you're saying
but she's such a victim and if you don't
what do what i want if you don't spend
those 3.5 trillion dollars then
this won't happen xyz won't happen that
i want to happen you're going to do this
to illegal immigrants or whatever it's
like you know what she was elected
kirsten cinema she's allowed to make
decisions and you're allowed to like
them or not like them but i'm telling
you guys what is happening right now
with the tacit approval from mainstream
media because they won't just call this
out is going to lead to something very
dangerous much like when all those
activists showed up at tucker carlson's
house remember that and his wife and his
two children had to hide they were they
showed up at his house outside of dc
tucker ended up leaving his house he no
longer lives there or in the same case
when mayor ted wheeler left the nut bag
portland mayor ted wheeler who destroyed
portland with his crazy lefty policies
well then activists showed up at his
house because he wasn't even left enough
for them and you know what he did he had
to move out of his apartment complex
well when will it be that they'll just
punch someone in the head perhaps
someone in a in a gorilla mask might
throw an egg at a california
gubernatorial candidate something crazy
like that then it continued when she
actually landed here's some video from
the airport
the irony as we finish up this segment
because you know i like to give you a
silver lining is that if you think that
these activists have in any way
influence kirsten cinema that she'll be
like you know what i was harassed enough
when they came up to me on the plane and
they came up to me in the bathroom and
they came up to me in the terminal i
finally thought about it and these
activists are right and i will sign that
bill that i think makes no sense and
i'll do what they want now i understand
there's an inclination to do that right
like there absolutely is and i think we
see a lot of this in public discourse
right now this is what sort of canceled
culture and the outrage mob is you
pressure someone enough with enough hate
online or showing up to their house or
on a plane or making it miserable when
they're at uh say uh going out to eat
which we played we played the video
yesterday the maxine waters video i
think we did right or did we not play it
on the show i put it on twitter you all
know that maxine waters video we'll pull
it up tomorrow because it's a perfect
example of this uh at the peak
of the riots the blm stuff and the
antifa stuff where she was screaming
about get in their face and if they're
out to eat show them well this is what
the democrats want they are telling you
exactly what they want and remember if
it was republicans doing any of these
things we'd be in an impeachment we'd be
in being told that white supremacy is
everywhere and all of the other crazy
nonsense so the silver lining is i don't
think this will push kirsten cinema i
understand the inclination to be like oh
i just want this to go away i'll sign
the freaking bill but i sense she's
realizing how rabid the the base is and
and this rabid activist genderless base
that the democratic party has is now in
complete control in complete control
except that there are two democrats who
are trying to stand for something
somewhat sane